Salut à tous, ravie de vous retrouver pour
ce sixième épisode de "La Modernité Kezako ?"
Souvenez-vous, entre le 4 et le 14 janvier
2011, une révolution éclata en Tunisie mettant
fin au régime autoritaire de Ben Ali, en
place depuis plusieurs décennies.
Un soulèvement de la population qui se manifesta
dans les rues et sur les réseaux sociaux.
Dans un pays où la censure était omniprésente,
Youtube et Dailymotion interdits (pour ne
citer que quelques exemples), la prise de
photographie très surveillée, les médias
contrôlés, et bien les tunisiens ont de manière
spontanée utilisé un moyen de communication
évident et élémentaire :
l’écriture
sur les murs.
Très rapidement, les murs de Tunis se sont
couverts de graffiti : slogans en plusieurs
langues, fresques murales, portraits peints.
Plus un pan de mur libre.
Sur l’un d’eux, on pouvait lire : « Murs
blancs, peuple muet ».
Quand tous les moyens de communication sont
verrouillés, ou qu’ils n’existent tout
simplement pas, il faut trouver d’autres
supports, n’importe quels supports :
les sols en goudron, les murs en béton.
On se retrouve alors dans une situation semblable
à celle que connurent les Hommes pendant
des siècles :  sans TV ,sans téléphone,
sans journaux, sans ordinateur.
(son de la mire)
A Tunis, les raisons de la contestation étaient
politiques, on critiquait le pouvoir en place,
on exigeait des élections démocratiques
via des messages et graffiti anti-gouvernementaux.
Magdy el Shafy, un dessinateur égyptien,
présentait le graff comme
« le ministère de la propagande révolutionnaire ».
La propagande…voilà
un thème qui va nous occuper dans cette vidéo.
Car, dans un tout autre contexte, ont lieu
cette année en France les élections présidentielles.
Bientôt les affiches, programmes, slogans
(officiels ou non) décoreront les murs des
villes.
Et comme à chaque événement politique,
cet affichage officiel suscitera des réactions
des citoyens, eux aussi utilisant les murs
!
La guerre des affiches arrive !
Mais l’utilisation du graffiti, comme moyen
de rébellion (par le peuple) ou de promotion
du pouvoir (par les élites), remonte à un
sacré bout de temps !
Rien qu’à la sonorité du mot « graffiti » on peut entendre
qu’il
ne s’agit pas d’un phénomène émergeant
dans les années 80.
Littéralement, le terme graffiti vient du
latin et désigne toute gravure à l’aide
d’un stylet sur un mur ou un objet.
Oubliez donc les ruelles de New York, les
métros berlinois et le quartier de Belleville
à Paris, car le graffiti, au sens le plus
commun « d’écrire son nom et laisser une
trace sur un mur », ça remonte au moins
à l’Antiquité.
Je vais vous parler du cas de Pompéi, cité
antique au sud de l’Italie qui, chaque année,
organisait des campagnes électorales pour
élire des magistrats.
Toute la ville se mobilisait pour cet événement.
Mais, avant de rentrer dans les détails de
cette organisation, je précise que toute
ressemblance avec les campagnes électorales
modernes est absolument fortuite…
Donc, que trouve-t-on à Pompéi ? Des affiches
! Plus de 2800 affiches et c’est un chiffre
qu’il faudrait revoir à la hausse, puisque
1500 d’entre elles concernent uniquement
la dernière campagne.
Ces affiches étaient, en réalité, des inscriptions
peintes sur les murs des bâtiments en lettres
rouges et noires.
Tous les ans on recommençait, et d’ailleurs,
on peut voir cette superposition.
Ces affiches, ou dipinti, servaient, comme
à notre époque, à soutenir la candidature
d’un personnage.
Le message véhiculé se compose de formules
passe-partout du type :
« Je vous prie de voter pour Untel » car il est « digne de gérer
les affaires publiques ».
Même si dans la campagne électorale, il s’est comporté
de manière opportuniste, évitant de détailler
son programme…hum, les habitudes ont la
vie dure.
Que faut-il pour être candidat à cette époque ? C'est à dire au
Ier siècle.
En réalité, deux choses sont essentielles
: la richesse et la notoriété.
Les candidats ne sont élus que pour leurs
qualités morales, leur honnêteté.
Les murs de Pompéi se couvrent d’inscriptions
qui célèbrent les qualités de celui qui
se présente : en somme, la base de toute
bonne campagne électorale !
Ce qu’il faut retenir c’est que l’élection à la romaine
se fait sur un nom plutôt que sur un programme.
Et au final tout est affaire de confiance…
Bien avant les tunisiens, les romains, avaient fait de la rue, le point de rencontre obligé
de tous les habitants issus de toutes les classes sociales.
Un badaud de cette époque ne pouvait échapper
aux injonctions multiples d’aller voter
: « Fais-le », « Allez
voter ! », car déjà l’abstentionnisme
était une préoccupation majeure.
On hésite pas à « réveiller » au sens
littéral du terme les citoyens :
« Untel, va voter, Tu dors ou quoi ? ».
Ces graffiti gravés à la pointe sèche par des habitants de la ville viennent bien souvent
soutenir ou, au contraire, contester la candidature d’un personnage.
Et tout le monde participe à ce petit jeu
: hommes, femmes, vieillards, saoulards (assez
nombreux pour le mentionner : « Salut à
vous ! Nous sommes de vraies outres ! » ! Il
y a également tous les commentaires qui s’éloignent
parfois du caractère électoral mais qui
témoignent quand même de l’utilisation
des murs à cette époque :
On part du militantisme avec un exemple
du même style que ceux que je vous ai donnés avant :
« Remue-toi, Trébius ! Elis édile
Lollius Fuscus, cet honnête homme ! ».
Pour arriver au monde des affaires :
En passant
par l’assistanat :
Pour finir en beauté
avec l’expression courtoise et très en vogue :
L’équivalent
aujourd’hui de notre bon « va tfaire enc***r".
Ca fait d’ailleurs relativiser le sempiternel « c’était mieux
avant », et le fait que l’injure serait
propre à notre époque.
Mais, qu’on se rassure, la sodomie est aujourd’hui,
comme la crucifixion jadis, une sentence qui
est aussi administrée par les forces de l’ordre…
Bon évidemment ces graffiti étaient pas destinés à traverser les siècles.
Puisque les murs sur lesquels écrivaient les auteurs étaient recouverts l'année suivante
Ils ont pu se conserver grâce à l’ensevelissement
de la cité par les cendres de l’éruption
du Vésuve en août 79 ap.J.-C.
De la même façon que les murs de Pompéi
ont été des outils de propagande politique
ou simples supports de communication des habitants,
les murs de nos villes modernes se couvrent
de messages avec toujours cette dichotomie
entre information officielle et critique de
ladite information sous la forme de tags.
Les dirigeants romains laissaient les murs
des édifices publics à la disposition des
habitants.
Car la propagande doit être diffusée, c’est
sa raison d’être.
En l’absence de radio ou de Twitter, vous
l’avez compris, c’est toute la ville qu’on
laissait libre comme support à l’expression.
A notre époque, en revanche, écrire sur
les murs, c’est une pratique contrôlée,
qui peut même être délictuelle.
Et ça constitue en soi, un acte
de révolte, même infime, face aux affiches
des pouvoirs en place.
Après ce que l’on vient de rappeler
pour la Tunisie, ou pour une époque bien
antérieure comme celle de Pompéi,
et bien on constate que les
murs sont toujours un moyen d’expression privilégié.
On a encore pu le constater au sujet des attentats
terroristes en France et ailleurs ces dernières années,
beaucoup de personnes ont spontanément exprimé
leurs sentiments à l’aide de craies sur
les façades et les trottoirs
Si on en croit le premier slogan que je vous
ai mentionné,
cela voudrait dire que nous sommes pourtant muets la plupart
du temps.
Ce que je vais vous dire est assez convenu
mais il me semble en fait que nos graffiti
ont été en partie dématérialisés.
Certains graffeurs continuent bien évidemment
d’orner les murs de nos villes mais ce sont
bien souvent des artistes qui s’y consacrent
à plein temps.
Pour ce qui est de la majorité des gens,
il faut dire qu’on écrit plus forcément
sur un mur en rentrant de soirée comme le
faisait Lucius il y a bientôt 2000 ans mais
on poste plutôt un petit commentaire sur
les réseaux sociaux.
D’ailleurs, c'est pas anodin que l’on
nomme encore cela
des murs.
(musique)